the sentiment of solidarity flowed thick
and fast in Strasbourg but will the glue
still stick time to find out welcome to
the agenda a joint sitting of the
Foreign Affairs a human rights and civil
liberties committee will meet to discuss
the issue of migrants there any Peas be
the only ones in attendance Commission
bigwigs are first vice-president frans
timmermans along with the High
Representative for foreign affairs
federica mogherini the Commissioner for
migration Dimitris avramopoulos and even
the UN HCR Frontex Chiefs will all
congregate to discuss the long road
ahead in helping those seeking refuge
and don't forget migration will also be
on the hot topics on Wednesday at the
mini plenary mbps will also debate the
agricultural crisis and the UN
sustainable development summit he had a
big week in Strasbourg but as mr.
Juncker comes to the Parliament to talk
tough on tax fraud is the former prime
minister of Luxembourg infra roasting
it's been on the cards for a while
finally Commission President jean-claude
Juncker will present new tax evasion
initiatives along with Commissioner p.m.
scritchy but if you remember the history
of the lux leak scandal we're under mr.
yonkers watch multinationals were given
favorable tax breaks he could be in for
a hard time the joint tax and economic
and Monetary Affairs Committee still
meet on Thursday the UK government
recently came under fire for carrying
out secret drone strikes against
suspected British to hardees in Syria
but drones aren't just for warfare
anyone can have them remotely piloted
aircraft systems or RPAs can be bought
online by just tube amp anyone but a
parliament report is in the pipeline
that looks to explore the innovation
potential of drones that will also look
to improve their regulation on the
market the transport committee votes on
Tuesday following the destruction of
ancient buddhas by the taliban in 2001
UNESCO issued a safeguard convention but
now Isis have taken up the baton and are
destroying the ancient city of Palmyra
is there any way to protect ancient
artifacts on Tuesday get ready for a
public debate with a director general of
unesco irina bokova could education at
the root level do enough to stamp
at radical thinking that people from all
walks of life are tolerant watch to find
out and that's all we have this agenda
take care and enjoy the week